do you feel like you uh do you make a
lot of big mistakes are you hard on
yourself or are you just kind of
easygoing and let things kind of flow
i'm not easygoing i'm i'm the hard
opposite of easygoing
and i make a shitload of mistakes but i
don't think you can parent and not make
mistakes because it's not an exact
science
it simply isn't you don't know the
personality of the child you're going to
have
you don't know what's going to work or
not work with that child and then if you
have another child
say you get in a groove with old number
one here comes number two with a whole
different set of criteria
not the same same not the same journey
to the child
and i'll say something to piggyback on
something you said
about like you think you'd you know
screw it up because you are
right now a man who is not
teamed up with somebody that you want to
enter this venture adventure with
like i think a lot of having children
for me
and i would love to hear rob's two cents
on this although i think i know what
he's gonna say
was i i've outpunted my coverage when it
came to
marrying somebody with attributes and
qualities that i admire
so the idea of teaming up with her to
have kids
i'm like we can do this sort of like all
right neither one of us know what we're
doing
but you liked your family i liked my
family and i like you and you like me
let's give this a go
and there's something very much like
rah-rah about it
that's part of the fun adventure and
challenge of having kids
is the team team element of it i mean i
can't imagine being a single dad i never
have been
knocking wood and a single mom even
harder
i i can't imagine that journey but for
me
being uh happily married
to somebody i admire and and when i see
attributes of her in my children i think
good
thank god they pulled that from my wife
that's great rob no
yeah rob you want to take that one yeah
you know for me it's a little bit uh
different now because like i said i've
been through this kind of life change
and um i find myself for the first time
uh parenting solo half the time the kids
are with me and i'm i'm by myself with
them
um uh certainly yeah i mean
and like to what i was saying earlier
like that's why my ex-wife and i still
have such a great relationship because
the children were created out of love
and our our joint
uh desire to do this together you know
and that just doesn't go away
um so certainly yeah that was the reason
i had kids it was the same
thing i was scared scared shitless uh
especially because
of what happened with my dad and i
didn't you know when i found out my
first born was going to be a son i was
like holy christ i don't know how to
i don't know how what it is to be a
father you know i mean i don't have
anything
any reference for being a father um and
uh
you know and another buddy of mine was
like well that's probably why you're
having a
son so you can figure that out right
you know but but now i find myself sort
of in this sort of new
world in terms of fortunately i've got
two really good kids they're
teenagers they you know uh they really
like
you know buddies that i need to feed
friends that i need to feed